in today's video we will be going
through the story of yorichi sugikuni
the first breathing style user and the
strongest demon slayer ever yorichi and
his twin brother michikatsu were born
into the tsugikuni clan within the
middle of the sengoku period a time when
twins were considered to be an extremely
bad omen yurichi in particular was born
with an odd birthmark on his forehead
which caused his father to declare that
he would kill him however their mother
flew into a rage and stopped him it was
eventually agreed upon that yorichi
would be sent to a temple to become a
monk when he turned 10 years old despite
their father's belief that the mark was
bad luck it actually granted yurichi
incredible physical prowess and the
ability to see the bodies of living
things in transparency yurichi grew up
very differently from michikatsu being
given much poorer food and education
than his brother and confined to a small
three-tatami room away from the rest of
the house he never spoke and was thought
to be deaf as a result his mother
subsequently made him hanafu do charm
earrings in the hopes the gods would
bless him with the ability to speak he
also was frequently seen clutching his
mother's side because of this michikatsu
found him pitiful still his brother
often snuck behind their father's back
to see yurichi even giving him a
handmade flute as a gift to comfort him
one day when he was seven yarichi smiled
and spoke for the first time declaring
his intent to become a samurai like his
brother after watching mijikatsu
practice sword swings startling him
however michikatsu was dismissive of
this sentiment as it was well known that
yurichi would be sent to the temple when
he turns 10. still one of their father's
men tasked with training mijikatsu
decided to humor yurichi showing him a
simple stance unexpectedly the young boy
flew into action after assuming the
stance landing four blows against the
man and shocking his brother who despite
his training had never landed one
however yurichi couldn't stand the
feeling of hitting someone and renounced
his goal to become a samurai michikatsu
often asked him about how he managed to
hit the man and he described what was
likely an early form of a breathing
style rather than talk about the sword
and training he happily told mijikatsu
he would rather fly kites with him
instead
when their mother passed away from her
illness yorichi went to michikatsu's
room at night to tell his brother the
news and bid him farewell planning to
leave for the temple that night he
expressed gratitude towards his brother
stating that he would always keep him in
mind and finally tucked away the flute
michikatsu had made for him earlier it
was later revealed to michikatsu through
their mother's diary that yurichi had
known everything about their mother's
illness how it weakened her left side
and yurichi's frequent attempts to
support her and help her move around it
was also revealed that yurichi knew his
father would make him his heir and send
mijikatsu to the temple due to his
newfound sword skills because of this
yurichi ran away from the house before
this could happen despite this kind act
michikatsu developed an intense hatred
and envy of yurichi for continuing to
surpass him in everything and
continually showing gratitude to gain
seemingly nothing after running straight
for one day and one night without any
sign of exhaustion into the mountains
yurichi met a girl around the same age
named utta whose entire family had died
yorichi chose to live with her and after
10 years uttan yurichi had married the
former becoming pregnant later just
before the expected arrival girichi left
home to summon a midwife promising his
wife to be back before the sunset on his
way urichi had helped an old man and
lost so much time that he decided to
return home and summon a midwife the
next day by then the sun had already set
when he finally arrived home he found
that utta and the unborn child were
killed by a demon the tragedy shocked
jorichi so much that he held her corpse
in his arms for 10 days straight and
only buried them after a pursuing demon
slayer encouraged him to do so this led
yurichi to pick up his blade again and
train as a demon slayer aided by his
demon slayer mark and innate talent for
swordsmanship yurichi proved to be an
incredibly powerful demon slayer he
reunites with michikatsu after the
latter's samurai encampment was
slaughtered by a demon and he was left
the sole survivor yurichi killed the
creature effortlessly and apologized for
the deaths of his brother's comrades
aided by his breathing technique later
named sun breathing and wanting to help
others yurichi tried to teach it to the
other demon slayers however no one could
match his form exactly undaunted he
modified the breathing techniques to
suit their strengths allowing them to
gain a similar increase in power and
abilities to help them hunt demons the
variations he created formed the first
water wind flame stone and thunder
breathing techniques and the best of
these demon slayers became known as the
hashira michikatsu himself tried and
failed to learn sun breathing instead
creating his own style he named moon
breathing soon yorichi encounters muzan
kibutsuji the progenitor demon and
mortal enemy of the demon slayers
accompanied by tamayo upon meeting him
urichi felt his rampant malicious intent
liking it to boiling magma from a
volcano ready to consume everything it
was then he reasoned he was born with
the skills and talent to defeat muzon
once and for all muzon stated that he
had lost interest in swordsmen who
employ breathing techniques and
performed long sweeps of his arms to
outright kill yurichi he dodged them but
instantly realized any of those attacks
would be fatal and felt fear for the
first time seeing into the transparent
world yurichi discerned muzon had seven
hearts and five brains that changed
position within his body seeing his
chance he combined all his forms into a
single attack cutting through them all
and overpowering muzon completely muzon
was left in disbelief at his inability
to regenerate while struggling to keep
his head attached yoricci asked him what
he felt was the value of life but didn't
receive an answer instead he turned to
tamayo but was surprised to see her
looking at her master's dismembered body
with a hopeful gleam in her eyes moving
to kill him once and for all yurichi
instead heard the sound of teeth
cracking as muzon's body burst into
hundreds of small pieces caught off
guard he was only able to destroy 1500
of the 1800 pieces leaving the rest to
escape from muzan to regenerate again in
spite of yorichi's failure to kill him
muzon never forgot the encounter and
remained fearful of yurichi for the rest
of his life tamayo was on the verge of
tears as she realized muzon learned how
to avoid death by decapitation cursing
the survival of the man that ruined her
life upon realizing that kibutsuji curse
failed due to muzon being weakened so
much tamayo was surprised yurichi
approaches her and she told him
everything he needed to know about muzon
and it was unlikely he would ever meet
him again as thanks for her aid he let
her go free soon after this several
demon slayers came to report to yurichi
that his brother had betrayed the
organization and become a demon yorichi
took responsibility for michikatsu's
betrayal his inability to kill muzon and
letting tamayo escape the other demon
slayers demanded he kill himself as
penance but the newly appointed oyakata
prevented him from doing so allowing him
to leave in banishment
after his banishment yaricci decided he
had much on his mind and wanted someone
to talk to he could only picture his
friends sumiyoshi and suyako and decided
to visit them he meets sumiyoshi sat
down with him and told him his entire
story from the beginning to his
banishment from the demon slayers
reminded of his tragedies and speaking
of his regret at letting muzan live and
the countless deaths that would follow
yorichi grew despondent sumir arrives at
that moment to ask for a hug at
sumiyoshi's request he lifts her up
making her laugh and squeal with joy
causing him to break down in tears and
embrace her suyaku arrived shortly after
to comfort him and treat yorichi to a
meal and cheer him up while with the
kamados yorichi would be asked to
perform the sun breathing's forms he
kindly did so performing all the moves
with such grace he was likened more like
a spirit than a human sumiyoshi would
watch this demonstration intently and
keep them in his memories on his last
night despite being told he was welcome
at any time yorichi gave sumiyoshi his
own hanafuda earrings sumiyoshi and
suyako realized that this was going to
be the last time he will ever see them
overcome with emotion sumi yoshi called
out to urichi as he walked away calling
him to stop he reminded that he saved
them and he voiced his promise to
preserve the sun breathing's forms
through his descendants hearing this
yurichi turns and smiles brightly
thanking the commodores and waving them
farewell despite the apparently limited
lifespan of 25 years suffered by those
who bore the demon slayer mark yaricci
lived till his 80s but eventually went
blind as he continued slaying demons
on the last day of his life he would
personally confront michikatsu now known
as kokushibo and muzan's strongest
lieutenant as upper rank 1 of 12 kizuki
devastated at what his brother had
become he cried and kokushibo could only
show disgust that his younger brother
was old but still alive despite having
the mark in spite of his love for him
yorichi knew he had to kill him and
prepared to strike kokushibo's disgust
turned to fear upon seeing that yoricci
still was the same capable and powerful
warrior from before he told his brother
when he was to attack and soon struck
slicing through his neck without
kokushibo able to even draw his blade
angered at being surpassed again
kokoshibo waited for the next attack
unfortunately it never came yorichi
passes from old age untouched angered
that his one chance at a fair battle is
gone and the man who nearly killed muzon
and him is now dead and undefeated
forever kokushibo would strike at his
brother's corpse in scorn only to
realize yorichi carried the flute he
gifted to him when they were both still
children unable to sever his connection
with yurichi kokushibo took the split
flute and carried it with him
click on this video where we explained
every breathing style in demon slayer
come on click it